votre but en blanc au jour 25 de la
campagne électorale c'est leur choix est
fait étudiants et électeurs peuvent déjà
aller votre plutôt le mieux selon moi
puis j'avais déjà pas mal fait mon idée
pour qui j'allais voter je suis pas
pratiquant plus qu'en plus du nouveau
règlement l'université pour voter je
pense que ça va aider à améliorer les
taux de participation dans un local de
l'université laval à québec en l'espace
d'une heure une trentaine d' électeurs
se sont présentés pour voter les jeunes
électeurs peuvent être inscrits dans
leur ville de résidence mais exercer
leurs droits sur le campus où il étudie
règle beaucoup de problèmes parce que
moi aller à drummondville j'ai pas le
temps puis surtout le jour de l'élection
ça tombe sûrement un moment où je vais
travailler je sais qu' on a des horaires
alloués pour aller voter
mais s'il faut que je fasse du nord et
demie de route pour y aller c'est pas
trop trop pratique à l'université
ryerson de toronto
l'ouverture d'un bureau de scrutin a
permis à un étudiant morial est de voter
pour la toute première fois il n'avait
pas encore 18 ans en 2015
c'est très bien parce que si c'était pas
là je pouvais pas voter parce que j'ai
pas le temps aller à montréal c'est sa
coach a aussi fait cas c'est très facile
je justifie ainsi à voter y avait peur
il y avait même pas un gros ligne avec
ce programme
élections canada souhaite voir augmenter
le taux de participation chez la plus
jeune cohorte des lecteurs les 18 24 ans
votent moins que les autres on sait
alors on fait des efforts
supplémentaires de là ce projet pilote
et vous savez qu'on à faire autre chose
de nouveau dans cette élection c'était
de permettre aux jeunes à partir de 16
ans de devenir des travailleurs
d'élections donc c'est les initie au
processus électoral
élections canada observe qu'en 2015 le
taux de participation a augmenté de près
de 19 points de pourcentage par rapport
à 2011 alors qu'il n'y avait pas de
bureau de vote dans les établissements
postsecondaires
cette donnée a encouragé le directeur
général des élections à reconduire
l'initiative
élections canada espère qu encore plus
de jeunes se prévaudront de leur droit
de vote cette année et si audrey paris
radio canada québec